this cost of living crisis is something
which is just heartbreaking in terms of
the the impact it has on people and we
know from a lot of the research that's
come out let's take trussell trust
an increase in use of food parcels last
year to 2.1 million through them a 14
increase we know that people are having
to make choices in terms of turning
heating off we know that people are
having to think about what they can eat
whether they can put food on the table
this is supposed to be a society where
there is compassion at the heart of it
and we're leaving people behind and it's
the fact that there was nothing in the
queen's speech yesterday that recognized
that there has to be a sense of urgency
people are facing real hardship
and this government is being tenured
the government would say in response
what do you want us to do you know we
did what we could during the pandemic we
had a global pandemic we we made sure
that people were being paid throughout
the pandemic we don't have a magic money
tree at the bottom of the garden of
course there isn't a magic money tree
but it's about the responsibilities that
you have and of course we've seen oil
companies like bp and shell release
their quarterly profits last week and we
saw that they're engaging in share
buybacks of billions of pounds because
they're making excess profits so there's
things that governments can do
we could have a windfall tax on all
those companies that are making excess
profits but the fact is okay when you
look at what the government is doing the
200 pounds loan is coming later this
year that's not acceptable it needs to
be brought forward and it needs to be a
grant government needs to recognize that
people are suffering today i mean if i
look at what we've done in scotland for
example we've introduced the child
payment initially at 10 pounds doubled
it to 20 we're increasing it to 25 we
increased the benefits under our control
by six percent now we're doing what we
can within the context of that that
devolved budget we've asked the
government to reverse the cut to
universal credit that would be 20 pounds
a week for people like dominic those
that are really struggling we need to
recognize a time like this
that we need to protect people that's
what government is there for and this uk
government's walking away i think is it
something like 600 pounds per household
is what it would it wouldn't be it you
know it wouldn't touch the same well
what we've argued for is the windfall
tax not just on our companies but all
those that have made excess profits over
the course of the of the pandemic but
government needs to accept its
responsibilities and it needs to make
sure that help is targeted and it's a
simple fact that people like dominic and
so many others millions of people are
going to have to make choices you know
when you hear from the likes of scottish
power years from tesco about they know
the pressure that their customers are
going to be under when you think about
if if i look to scotland we're going to
have half the adult working population
are going to be in fuel poverty
government has to step in to protect
people that's the obligation that
government has and to hear that there
isn't going to be an emergency budget
that rishi sudak is just walking away
from all of this not accepting his
responsibilities we've been calling for
an emergency budget it needs to happen
because we need to respond to the scale
of the crisis how you feeling about the
northern ireland protocol and what might
happen to it i'm worried about that um
you know we've all got memories of the
past the troubles in northern ireland
and the peace has been hard won we need
to make sure that the good friday
agreement is protected but within all of
that this uk government signed up to its
form of brexit the prime minister is
responsible for that you cannot tear up
an international treaty we cannot risk
as they seem to be doing in the teeth of
all of this with all the problems we've
got that the uk government is
effectively threatening a trade war with
europe but we can't also allow the
people of northern ireland to be
suffering in the way that they are of
course we shouldn't but that's where you
need diplomacy you need to get round the
table whether you agree that it needs to
be changed just i agree that we agree
that we need to well we need to deal
with the consequences of the deal that
boris johnson's government has struck
that's caused the problem but but let's
use diplomacy to get through this let's
work with all the politicians in in
northern ireland the election that took
place last week we need to find a way
through this that gives security to
people in the ireland but the most
important thing
is preserving peace
and alongside that of making sure that
we accept our international obligations
that boris johnson signed up for
and moving from the rhc to the channel
and
european union leaders a warning of a
trade deal
and a problem with trade wars shall we
put it um as bluntly as that if we do
have a problem with the northern ireland
protocol uh michael go sat there a
couple of hours ago and he said tosh
it's not gonna happen
well you know one of the things we've
seen over the course of the last couple
of years anyway and it's been obscured
by what's happened with covid that we
have a right we use a scotch word we
have a right boorick in terms of our
trading relationships
it's a mess it's a shambles
if you want to put it that way
companies in my constituency right
across scotland right across the uk
really struggling you know when you talk
about the cost of living crisis we know
from the data that food prices are six
percent higher as a direct consequence
of brexit so governments cause these
problems and it's not good enough for
michael gove and others just to shrug
their shoulders they have to accept
responsibility for the mess that they
have created
as far as the queen's speech is
concerned we've touched on that um a
little bit of course um haven't we um
was there anything meaty in it for you i
was talking to labour a few minutes ago
and they were saying that it was it was
gruel
well it's it's a it's a massive missed
opportunity and the fact that there's
nothing on the cost of living crisis the
fact that when we look at what they're
doing on brexit legislation now we have
in scotland in all the devolved
administrations we've enshrined eu law
into our own law what we're seeing out
of all of this is yet again another
power grab it's the disrespect that's
been shown to the devolved
administrations it's not good enough and
this whole idea that legislation in
london in westminster needs where it's
appropriate the consent of the devolved
parliaments they're running roughshod
over the principles of devolved
government as a consequence of what
they're doing it simply isn't good
enough and it's right for just uh i
wanted to get your view on kiestarma as
well
we know that there's an investigation we
also know that he tweeted in march of
this year that because the prime
minister was being investigated a
criminal investigation he should resign
so
why shouldn't that law also or that that
view also apply to the opposition i
think two things kate i mean we had the
queen's speech yesterday we had the
prime minister standing at the dispatch
box the first prime minister in history
to have been found to have broken his
own laws and he's sitting at that that's
about dispatch box he should have gone
like as far as keira's concerned and
i'll applaud him for what he did the
other day by saying that if he's found
guilty he will resign i have to say that
he's actually shown leadership and
leadership that's not been shown by the
the prime minister and i thank kier for
the stands that he's taken however he
did say that the prime minister should
resign because he was subject to a
criminal investigation and yet so is he
well let's but yeah but you know when
you look at the facts of the matter more
than 50 people find around downing
street the culture of partying that's
going on let's wait and see what happens
with the police investigation to at
durham and i'm sure that cair will
accept his responsibility but he didn't
want to wait for the outcome of the
police investigation he said the prime
minister should resign because he was
subject to an investigation we have with
the prime minister and those around them
at number 10 is a culture of partying
breaking their own laws on multi
occasions and we'll wait to see what
happens with the ending of the the
police inquiry and we'll eventually get
the sugary report but we can't have that
equivalence from what has happened with
keir starmer and what has happened with
boris johnson and those around them but
i'm sure if keira is in the wrong keir
will accept his responsibilities as he
should because that's what dignity and
respect of the office that we all hold
in public life is about that's something
that the prime minister should should
realize i think he's probably feeling a
bit ganged up on by you lot because
you're all saying um no no no no no you
immediately you should have gone and he
actually put it in writing on a tweet
it's the leader of the opposition but
you don't think the same rules should
apply to him you know the facts of the
matter are it's a prime minister that's
broken the law it's a prime minister
didn't know that at the time i i think
there was very clear evidence of what
was going on from everything that came
out we knew that there was a culture of
partying going on we've seen all the
evidence that there's more to come we
cannot equate the behavior of the prime
minister with what has happened to keir
starman durham good to talk to you as
always mr blackford thank you for
joining us on the program thank you